großbritannien ist durch die wahl beiden
in einer ganz ganz schlechten lage sie
haben könnte trump war ein brett
befürworter und ein freund von boris
johnson der beiden ist ein ihre von
herzen her und dem break sind extrem
kritisch gegenüber das heißt die
verhandlungsposition der verein auf der
hand das heißt verhandelt schon von
großbritannien ist sehr schlecht wir
sind jetzt in der letzten phase des
black seeds was was fällt in foreign
office ein also dem auswärtigen amt von
england wir müssen jetzt unsere
geheimwaffe in stellung bringen und
schicken rolls nach berlin und gute
stimmung bei merkel zu machen weil man
natürlich nicht ganz zu unrecht annimmt
dass deutschland eine gehörige eine
wichtige stimme ist in der eu und wenn
in diesen letzten phase der
eu-verhandlungen sozusagen die frau die
die berlin bischen sympathie hat mit dem
briten und sagt lasst uns nicht so
streng sein mit dem fischereirechte und
lass uns dir ein bisschen hingegen kommt
mit irland dann könnte das sozusagen der
durchbruch sein das ist ein
hochpolitisches lächelnd ich will dass
das beispiel auch zeigt dass es eben
nicht nur um royals geht also das hält
sich so mein hauptthema wie ihr wisst
aber den punkt den ich da finde erst
hatte ich schon mal die gelegenheit
camilla und prinz kennenlernen zu dürfen
und habe die als sehr sehr freundlich
empfunden und sehr intelligent und sehr
politisch interessiert habe durch die
britische botschaft kennengelernt und
die haben zum beispiel auch die frauen
aus gefangenschaft haben die eingeladen
nach england ins haus und camilla mit
der konnte ich auch ein paar worte
wechseln die hat sich auch nach dem
schicksal erkundigt also eine sehr
politische frau sagt ich sie
wahrgenommen ich finde das besondere an
beiden ist eigentlich das hoffnungs
moment und das ist so das glaube ich wo
ganz viele menschen gerade nach lechzen
in zeiten von so vielen schlechten
nachrichten hintereinander weg und und
da sage ich es gibt eben sozusagen
hoffnungsträger die weko adel schon
kennen aus der vergangenheit aber es
gibt ja auch neue hoffnungsträger und
[Musik]